foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory today we're going to be
discussing religion and Christmas in
Harry Potter peeling back the layers to
uncover if Christmas means the same
thing in the magical world as it does in
the Muggle World we'll also be more
broadly addressing the topic of religion
in Wizarding Society including its
prevalence diversification and whether
or not witches and wizards celebrate
god-like figures we're going to start
with Christmas then segue into religion
let's get into it Christmas time at
Hogwarts meant that it was time for
Hagrid and the other professors to
outfit the Great Hall with Christmas
decorations and 12 large decorated fur
trees mistletoe and Holly were among the
decorations that Hagrid and the other
professors helped put in the Great Hall
for the Christmas holidays on the
surface Christmas in Harry Potter
appears to be celebrated very much the
same way that it celebrated in mukul
society with with eggnog carols lights
trees presents and Christmas feasts
Harry had never in all his life had such
a Christmas dinner a hundred fat roast
turkeys mountains of roast and boiled
potatoes platters of chipolatas terrines
of buttered peas silver boats of thick
Rich gravy and cranberry sauce and
stacks of wizard crackers every few feet
along the table in fact the emphasis
placed on Christmas traditions in Harry
Potter is so significant that the
franchise in some ways has transcended
the page becoming immortalized in the
real world as a story that's become
synonymous with Christmas itself as soon
as the snowy season hits It's inevitably
time to hunker down in some blankets and
throw on Harry Potter but besides all of
the warm jumpers gingerbread houses and
Christmas pudding what is the actual
significance of Christmas in Harry
Potter is Christmas and Harry Potter
driven by religion or is it a secular
holiday first I'm going to take a look
at What Christmas Means to witches and
wizards then I'm going to dive into the
role of religion in The Wizarding World
as a whole from our perspective pretty
much everyone in Harry Potter seems to
celebrate Christmas if there was a
character from another faith that
celebrated some other form of winter
holiday you'd expect that Harry would
have heard about it but provided that
Christmas was traditionally a religious
holiday and that seemingly everyone
celebrates it in the story does that
mean everyone's a Christian this is
going to have a multi-part answer the
first thing I'd like to point out is
that Christianity is mentioned in Harry
Potter the story is certainly not devoid
of any religious references for example
the fat Friar Hogwarts ghost was a
wizard and part of the church who was
executed when senior Churchman grew
suspicious of his supernatural abilities
specifically his ability to cure pox by
poking peasants with a stick and his
habit of pulling rabbits out of the
communion cup JK Rowling has also
alluded to the fact that the books
explore Christian themes of sacrifice
and Resurrection specifically
referencing the Tombstones found in
godric's Hollow to me the religious
parallels have always been obvious
Rowling said but I never wanted to talk
too openly about it because I thought it
might show people who just wanted the
story where we were going at the end of
her latest and final installment in the
series there are specific references to
Christianity and themes of life after
death and Resurrection at one point
Harry visits the grave of his parents
and finds two biblical passages
inscribed on two separate tombstones
they are very British books so on a very
practical note Harry was going to find
biblical quotations on tombstones she
said but I think those two particular
quotations he finds on the Tombstones
they sum up they almost epitomize the
whole series the tombstone for Harry's
parents reads The Last Enemy that shall
be destroyed is death
and Ariana Dumbledore's reads where your
treasure is there will your heart be
also these are Bible quotes on the
Tombstones of witches and wizards yes
Lily Potter and Kendra Dumbledore were
muggle bonds but their funerals were
held by Wizards in The Wizarding World
the fact that there were religious
citations on their graves is likely
indicative of religious prevalence in
Wizarding Society however it could also
Simply Be Wizards choosing to honor the
known religions of the deceased I could
read into these quotes all day but
that's not the purpose of today's video
all I wanted to demonstrate is that
there are obvious references to
Christianity sprinkled throughout the
story which makes sense given that
Rowling is in fact a Christian with that
said it is highly likely that there are
witches and wizards in Harry Potter who
follow Christianity whether these
beliefs were adopted from the Muggle
world there's anyone's guess but given
the proximity of these two co-existing
worlds it's not surprising that one
would rub off on the other furthermore
plenty of Hogwarts students come from
the Muggle World which means they would
bring their belief systems with them to
Hogwarts supporting this is the fact
that Easter another religious holiday is
also celebrated in The Wizarding World
but does that mean Christianity is the
only religion in Harry Potter and does
it mean that all Hogwarts students are
Christians certainly not what we have to
remember about Christmas is that these
days it's less a religious holiday and
more just a cultural tradition
especially in Britain since the early
20th century Christmas has become a
secular holiday that's observed by
Christians and non-christians alike
devoid of any kind of Christian elements
those who follow Christianity May
celebrate Christmas the way it was
intended to be celebrated but for
everyone else it's more about what it
has become culturally a time to get
together with family exchange gifts put
up a tree and sit around the fire okay
so Christianity he is prevalent in
Wizarding Society but what about the
other religions the first direct quote
from rolling on the religion of witches
and wizards was in 2007 where she
revealed that Hogwarts is a multi-faith
school never specifying what those
faiths may or may not be following that
she responded to a tweet in 2014 where
she confirmed that there was a Jewish
Ravenclaw student by the name of Anthony
Goldstein and following that we got the
biggest piece of info on Wizarding
religion yet where she revealed there is
room for every religion belief system at
Hogwarts other than wiccans to everyone
asking whether their religion belief
non-belief system is represented at
Hogwarts the only people I never
imagined there are wiccans for those
unfamiliar with Wicca here's the
definition from Encyclopedia Britannica
Wicca the largest of the modern Pagan or
neo-pagan religions its followers who
are called wiccans typically identify as
a switches and draw inspiration largely
from the pre-christian religions of
Europe having publicly emerged in
England during the 1950s weka is now
found primarily in Western countries and
the number of wiccans is probably in the
low hundreds of thousands followers
often use the pentagram or five-pointed
Star as the main symbol of their
religion I believe that by condemning
wiccans Rowling is simply trying to
further distance herself from them
namely due to the Flack she gets for her
story and the magic in the story being
in a front on Christianity there are
many references to Witchcraft in the
Bible with almost all of them directly
condemning it and provided that one of
the key thematic elements of Harry
Potter is witchcraft it has been
unsurprisingly opposed by a certain
religious groups for example Deuteronomy
18 11 12 condemns anyone who casts bells
or who is a medium or spiritist or who
consults the dead anyone who does these
things is to testable to the Lord and
because of these detestable practices
the Lord your God will drive out those
Nations before you and exodus 22 18
states do not allow a sorceress to live
JK Rowling has insisted that magic and
Harry Potter is secular a product of
Science and not religion it does not
depend on active intervention by a God
or Gods this is consistent with her
condemnation of Wicca which believes
magic to be spiritual in nature even
though wiccans use terms like Wizard and
wedge it is not the same as what's
present in Harry Potter Rowling spoke on
this it's a different concept of magic
to the one laid out in the books so I
don't really see how they can co-exist
however regardless of rolling statements
and reassurances that the magic is
science-based the books are still a
no-go for Many religious families
hopefully as time goes on Rowling's
comments on this topic will alleviate
some of the fears experienced by
religious groups and open up the story
to more fans Okay so we've confirmed the
prevalence of Christianity and we've
also confirmed that the only religious
group excluded from Wizarding Society
are wiccans I mean it makes perfect
sense that there would be a plethora of
wizards with varying religious beliefs
present at Hogwarts especially if we
consider the fact that muckleborn
Wizards have been around since Hogwarts
was founded but what evidence do we have
of these other religions if we hone in
on Hogwarts in particular it doesn't
seem like being actively religious would
be all that easy there's no mention of
students attending a church or School
Chapel on Sundays and there's no mention
of bar mitzvahs or Muslim Students
prayer time perhaps these things are
prevalent in the magical world but
merely excluded due to the fact that we
are looking at the Wizarding World
primarily through the lens of Harry a
muggle-raised boy with a fairly narrow
perspective and that's it for today's
topic I hope you enjoyed it if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember to the well-organized Mind
death is but the next great adventure
foreign